[Music]
there are many misconceptions about
being a coder or a programmer and today
I really want to debunk them before we
get into this I just want to quickly say
a massive thank you to penguin Random
House for sponsoring this video
and not only sponsoring it but also for
bringing this book wizards and robots to
my attention it's a book written by
will.i.am and its primary focus was to
try and get young people more interested
in programming and computer sciences
which i think is great for someone who
is known to be a creative individual to
do something like this it shows that
people who are interested in these sorts
of things they aren't just how the media
might portray them or how we might
envision them being in our minds and
let's talk about that right now let's
get the first point out of the way
coding is hard really really hard if you
want to be a programmer you're gonna
have to work the hardest you've ever
worked before not true just like
anything else you might want to learn
coding no it's not necessarily easy but
it can be learnt by anyone all you need
is passion and determination and you got
this I like to think of coding as a
version of learning another language
however it's kind of like a magic
language because you get to influence
technology and in this day and age where
we're using technology every single day
that gives you power
just just think about that something
from this point to coders are genius
it's like you have to have massive brain
to be a coder not true coders are often
seen as these extremely intelligent
individuals who just sit in front of a
computer and type out an alien language
that nobody else can understand and
that's really not how it is coding is
more about problem solving and logic and
guess what it's kind of what we do
every day as human beings anyway I
believe a Coda's superpower is failure
I'm becoming comfortable with failure
and that's one of the reasons why I'm so
glad I did learn how to code because it
teaches you that actually failure is
just the first step to success you need
to learn how to debug how to fail and
then figure out why you're failing to
then succeed in what you want to do this
is kind of proof that no coders aren't
super intelligent they're just okay with
failing a bunch of times until they
finally get it work and their code
finally works it's just how it is and
that's how we are as humans the next
point you must be a mathematician very
good at mathematics I am NOT gonna lie
maths was my most dreaded subject in
school I've really found it difficult I
wasn't an overachiever and I tried very
hard to be average at mathematics
however I would say that I am a coder I
have worked as a front-end web developer
I am now developing games and c-sharp so
I know how to code but I'm not an
amazing mathematician of course you
still need the basic knowledge of
algebra and things like that that's not
what a coder does they spend most of
their time writing the language of
computers / writing mathematics formulas
and also to be a coder there's a bunch
of different types of coders that you
might want to be as I already said I was
a front-end web developer front-end
meaning it's more about the design and
the look and kind of the interaction on
the surface level I didn't have to
figure out many mathematical formulas
because that's was the job of a back-end
developer Google that if you want
because that's that's too much to
explain in this video but basically
different types of coders need a basic
understanding of math yes but you don't
need to be a mathematician genius so
many people think that you need a
science degree to be a
and of course that seems like the
logical option to go to university and
study it properly just like it is for
anything that you might want to learn
however in this digital age and if you
have gotten to this point and you've
realized that you do have what it takes
to become a coder and anyone can do it
then there are many more ways to learn
how to code outside of the stereotypical
education system for instance I didn't
go to university before getting my job
as a front-end web developer I went
through an apprenticeship instead in the
evenings I would learn on code Academy
code Academy is a website that's free
and teaches you how to code all you need
is to believe in yourself to have self
motivation and a computer a computer
would help internet connection to you
there are loads of websites like code
Academy which I will put their links in
the description below for you to check
out and as well as websites that teach
you there's also websites where you can
simply ask questions and get in touch
with the coding community it's very open
source they love to help each other out
and it makes the whole process easier
because no coders are geniuses this
brings me to point number five that is
coding is boring to learn and teach it's
not true these websites that I've just
explained to you they are gamified so
you get badges and points for learning
which I found really fun I'm a gamer
anyway I'm competitive so I wanted to
kind of up my school get the new badges
and things like that I'm not only that
the lessons that they provide are just
really interesting there's so many
things that you can do with code yes you
can build a website and things like that
but also you can animate in code and
there is website Khan Academy and I
remember doing my first ever animate
with css3 lessons and I found them
much fun there's also a bunch of more
physical and practical projects that you
can do anniversary pie are great for
getting young people involved in
programming and coding by using a small
computer this computer has GPIO pins got
everything you need to do physical
programming as well as screen based
programming you can make robots and
stuff like that robots how is that
boring I don't know not to me anyway
number six the best programmers are
young so if you didn't start young then
there's no point you learning how to
code now this is bogus I mean I kind of
understand it because technology is
advancing so so quickly so you have to
keep up with that however I think this
very reason means that no matter what
age you start you're always going to be
on the same level unlike say learning a
guitar or something like that where when
you start young it really does help you
because that's not actually going to
change you're just going to get better
at it but coding does change so it
really doesn't matter what age you start
learning as long as you're passionate
and motivated enough to keep up with it
and have fun with it
there's always more to learn with coding
and technology that's what I find so
exciting about it because you are never
going to be perfect at it there's always
going to be more to learn so let's get
into the more physical and kind of
personal attributes of what people think
in their heads when they hear the term
coder or program coders are nerds no not
every coder spends their spare time
watching reruns of Star Trek or eating
chips on the sofa while they're playing
games it sounds weird missing chips I
mean I mean like Doritos but
chips are an American word anyway no
they're not wearing comfy jeans all the
time no they are always wearing a meme
top with some crazy clever coding joke
on it and no they're not always awkward
around the opposite sex either all you
need is a brain and a computer coders
can be anyone any gender any age any
style any personality attribute that you
can think of they could be a coder just
like anything they could be anything so
just stay open-minded number eight
coders are antisocial habits it's often
perceived that code is work alone in
dark and quiet rooms or even better in
their mom's basement but this simply is
not the case I mean I do have to admit I
do like to not be sociable when I'm
trying to crack a problem what I'm
trying to figure out what syntax I
should be using to problem-solve like
anything if you're doing this and
someone interrupts your thought process
you kind of lose your train of thought
and then it goes and gets lost
however coders also need each other they
need people because if they can't
problem-solve on their own the very best
thing to do is to share that problem
with a co-worker with someone else even
if they don't really understand code
it's good to kind of walk through what
your problem is what you've done to try
and fix that problem and take them
through step by step because as I said
coding is all about problem solving and
working together to solve that problem
often helps and they've already kind of
touched on the fact that there are lots
of open-source communities and online
places for people to help you with your
current coders want to help each other
they want to talk to each other they
want to come up with great ideas
together and there are also events for
coders and programmers like hackathons
where they'll spend whole weekend's of
those are people just being together
working together having fun together
so it shows that
they're not always just on their own in
their rooms working alone as a coder
it's a rite of passage to become an
anonymous hacker to break into the lot
online accounts and to tamper with the
website to make your life a little less
secure no hell no hacking is a
completely different way of coding just
like I explained to you front end a
back-end development different types of
coding just because you know how to code
does not mean that you necessarily know
how to hack into someone's personal
private details and also it's just
Mobile's just because you know how to
code doesn't mean that you're going to
use this ability to do something illegal
online don't be worried about that
someone says that they know how to code
it does not mean that they know how to
hack into your bank account and take all
your money know and finally the one that
gets to me the very most coding is not
creative not all code is a series of
ones and zeros although there was a
creative freaking genius that turned
binary code into Star Wars which is
pretty cool I'll try and get that up on
screen for you and you can watch sides
it's Star Wars in binary with ones and
zeroes how crazy is that
and that just shows you that if you are
a creative person if you want to think
creatively coding gives you more
opportunities to do this because you're
able to perform interactions with
whatever you are creating think about it
games are creative it's a way of telling
a story and of course you need to code
to do that there are even people using
code to make interactive film to make
elements of their video stay relevant so
using a graph that will always use
relevant data and as this all progresses
there are ways that people who perhaps
aren't so technically minded and are
more into the design element of things
that they can create experiences that
before would have been primarily codes
so I mean unity3d which is what I used
to make gains it's easily laid out you
don't have to write heaps and heaps of
code but obviously having the basic
understanding allows you to do more with
it the more codes you understand the
more the doors open up and the more you
have creative freedom with other
creative mediums like writing or films
you're basically creating a passive form
of entertainment but with code you get
to manipulate data you get to use
relevant information and you get to
merge this with your creation perhaps
you can visualize the whole world
emotions by using tweets being pulled in
real-time you're looking for a motive
words and seeing which emotion is being
used the most yes these are real-world
things I'll put some links in the
description below
I personally now I'm actually using the
Facebook SDK in my next video game just
to make the whole experience more
personal to that person who is
experiencing that's a creative thing and
now my whole brain is basically there's
a lot you can do with it it is creative
and anyone who says it's not I'm just
like and knowing that just the whole
premise of coding is problem-solving to
be creative you have to come up with
ideas you have to problem-solve how
you're going to realize these ideas in
the real world that's what coding is all
about again I just want to say a massive
thank you to penguin Random House to
sponsoring this video and also bringing
to my attention the book by will.i.am
wizards and robots the fact that
will.i.am has made this book which by
the way is about wizards and robots at
war together and a computer scientist
who made the first robot pretty darn
cool and to show that he's interested in
all of that just shows that anyone can
be interested and can do it if they want
to you don't have to be male or female
you don't have to be a nerd you don't
have to be unsociable you don't have to
be awkward
you don't have to be old you don't have
to be young you don't have to be born
here or born on the other side of the
world
anyone can be a coda I really hope that
this has made you think about
programming and coding a little bit
differently if you are interested in it
there will be a bunch of bunch of bunch
and links down below that can help you
get started you can do it because hey
you're not the stereotypical coder
because that doesn't exist let me know
in the comments below if this has
changed your mind or if you're a coda
and you agree or if you disagree and
want to know that as well there'll also
be a link to Williams book war below
it's not actually war it's like wizards
and robots but obviously there's a war
going on between them so you can check
them out if you want to if you like
wizards if you like a robots if you like
computer sciences you might enjoy his
book have a lovely day or evening bye
[Music]